anthe Weiner is back in the news and he  was again this is insane  caught sending racy pictures to a woman  who is not his wife  the New York Post published this picture  he sent pretty unbelievable that is his  son lying next to him unbelievable  Weiner says the pictures weren't  inappropriate and he was just chatting  about his day well the guy has a point  check out some of the other pictures he  apparently sent just rescued these  little critters finally reading that  book you recommended look who's digging  this new Frank Ocean album wishing a  happy retirement to CBS News Sunday  mornings Charles Osgood hey looks like  someone's excited the nice guys is  finally out on blu-ray congratulations  to Beyonce on her empowering VMA  performance she's inspirational women  everywhere hashtag yes all women heard  about taco bells new gordita supreme  comma and finally hey I figured out  where Belarus's  [Applause]  you